salut à vous qui regardez cette vidéo
juste avant qu'elle commence j'ai la
bonne nouvelle à partager la tournée du
spectacle reprend je serai en suisse les
10 et 11 septembre à annecy le 12 le 17
à lille ensuite j'enchaîne avec
saint-amand-les-eaux dans le 59 avec
longjumeau avec fleury les aubrais
bordeaux gérardmer genève anthouard de
bretagne bressuire tour il ya toute la
tournée en descriptions et la dernière
ultime de singularité aura lieu au
zénith de paris le 11 décembre bref si
vous voulez des infos ou réservés vous
avez le lien dans la description j'ai
hâte de vous retrouver sur scène
ça lui qui n'a jamais rêvé d'avoir des
super pouvoirs de devenir invisible
d'avoir une force démesurée de voler
dans les airs tout en défendant la veuve
et l'orphelin ça les super héros ils
savent le faire depuis très longtemps
d'ailleurs et on adore ça
[Applaudissements]
mais si les super héros était notre
mythologie contemporaine à nous un peu
notre omer passé plutôt l'odyssée de
leurs origines aux véritables justicier
en collant qu'on peut croiser dans
certaines villes aujourd'hui parce
qu'apparemment pour être un justicier
une fois avoir une paire de collants je
vous emmène à la découverte des origines
des super héros et surtout c'est ça qui
m'intéresse de leur influence
comportement loïc ce générique ce
rapport à astérix parce que c'est un
super héros
l'origine des super héros les premières
histoires des super-héros date d'un
petit bout de temps puisqu'elles sont
apparus avec les mythologies qui datent
pour certaines quand même de plus de
3000 ans avant notre ère les super héros
de l'époque sont des dieux évidemment
qui pour certains étaient garnies de
superpouvoirs une belle palette quelques
uns sont d'ailleurs toujours exploités
aujourd'hui comme tort par exemple qui
est directement issue de la mythologie
nordique et qui en tant que dieu du
tonnerre à des super-pouvoirs
métérologiques pas facile hein
météorologiques et plus récemment au 19e
siècle c'est la notion de surhomme qui
apparaît dans les romans feuilletons
alors les romands sont diffusés sous
forme d'épisodes dans dans des journaux
à l'époque et on attendait ça un petit
peu comme on attend aujourd'hui est le
dernier épisode de la série qu'on
regarde les romans feuilletons
apparaissent en 1836 et le personnage de
surhommes il y aurait fait ses premiers
pas en 1844 avec le comte de monte
cristo d'alexandre des personnages aux
capacités supérieures à celles des
hommes lambda font alors leur apparition
comme en 1887 avec sherlock holmes et
ses capacités extraordinaires de
déductions qu'on retrouvera d'ailleurs
dans les comic books par la suite payant
pourrait se demander c'est quoi les
notions qui font qu'un héros devient un
super-héros en 1909 c'est le roman
l'homme qui peut vivre sous l'eau qui
débarque dans lequel le héros est un
homme à qui on en a greffé des branchies
l'auteur français jean de l'aïr créera
ensuite le personnage de nick talopp en
1911 qui spoiler est un personnage qui
voit la nuit nyctalope c'est pas une
insulte mais les véritables super héros
tels qu'on les connaît et qu'on est
reconnu aujourd'hui apparaissent en 1938
avec superman dans le tout premier
numéro du comic book américain action
comics deux ans plus tard et captain
america qui voit le jour un super héros
patriotique qui est créé en réponse au
régime nazi avant même que les états
unis ne s'engagent dans la seconde
guerre mondiale d'ailleurs suivent
ensuite tout ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui les séries télé sont créés à
partir de la fin des années 40 et des
films quelques années plus tard
aujourd'hui les super héros sont
clairement manger à toutes les sauces en
dehors des véritables super héros les
vrais écran slip en collant qui se
baladent dans nos villes comme on verra
tout à l'heure on a bien sûr les bons
gros blockbuster avec les avengers mais
aussi des anti héros comme kick ass ou
deadpool ou encore les séries à la the
boys on découvre l'envers du décor d'une
industrie de héros qui est pas si sympa
parce que vraiment
quand homeland heures il te sourit t pas
tant à l'aise en fait tu te dis tiens je
vais mourir et puis il a l'air gentil
plutôt envie de mourir petite parenthèse
aussi pour vous dire que justement
l'envers du décor des super héros c'est
ce que vous allez trouver le mois
prochain dans votre boîte aux lettres
puisque le prochain numéro de curieuses
mon magazine vous savez contient presque
dix pages sur le sujet ainsi qu'une
présentation des oeuvres de sacha
goldberger un photographe français qui a
créé des photos très stylé de
super-héros version renaissance et je
vous avoue que hulk et batman en
collerette c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on peut voir ça vous avez le lien
dans la description pour découvrir mon
magazine et les quinze numéros déjà
sortis pour rappel l'abonnement annuel
de la version papier c'est 30 euros par
an 29 90 pour recevoir les dix numéros
de 60 pages directement dans votre boîte
aux lettres ou vous habitiez dans le
monde frais de port inclus et 19 90 et
la version numérique pourquoi les yeux
le groupe laisse mais alors que font les
super héros sur notre cerveau pour qu'on
les apprécie tant est qu'on en redemande
depuis plus d'un siècle on les aime ok
mais c'est pas suffisant comme répond
des chercheurs de l'université de
stanford ont réalisé une expérience ils
ont pris deux groupes de personnes qui
l'ont plongé dans une réalité virtuelle
où un tremblement de terre devait avoir
lieu le premier groupe est installé dans
un hélicoptère pour une simple mission
de reconnaissance
le second groupe pouvait se déplacer à
la manière de superman et avait pour
mission de sauver un enfant malade
séparé de ses parents après cette petite
expérience les cobayes devaient répondre
à un questionnaire mais pour chacun
d'entre eux l'employé qui a porté le
document à remplir faisait tomber son
stylo sur 60 personnes testées 54 l'ont
aidé à ramasser son stylo et de quel
groupe faisait partie les six qui n'ont
pas bougé leurs petits doigts pour
amasser le stylo d'après vous ceux qui
étaient dans l'hélico t'es pas un super
héros le fait de s'identifier à un super
héros quand on regarde un film une série
où quand on lit un comics développerait
donc l'altruisme du lecteur du
spectateur de plus on sait que le fait
d'être altruiste développent un
sentiment de bien-être et de bonheur
chez des personnes qui en font preuve ça
aurait même un petit effet antidouleur
pourquoi s'en priver ramasser les stylos
qui tombe une autre étude new yorkais
cette fois montrent que le fait de créer
un lien parra social avec batman par
exemple même sur le rencontrer en chair
et en os améliore la perception que l'on
a de notre propre corps les sujets de
l'expérience voient même leur force
augmenté lorsqu'ils sont face à une
image de leur super héros favoris ça me
fait penser un petit peu aussi à la
vidéo sur sur les paras potes dont par
le cirrus mars si vous voulez regarder
excellente vide l'image et des actions
de nos justiciers en collant préféré a
donc une conséquence sur notre
comportement et notre confiance en nous
d'autres chercheurs américains de
l'université de cornell cette fois ci
ont montré que de faire manger des
pommes au super héros donc dans les bd
dans les séries ou dans les films plutôt
que des frites permettait de faire
manger plus sainement les enfants qui du
coup vous voulez manger comme le super
héros manipulation positive on rappelle
un livre en plus de tout ça nous avons
un autre lien quotidien celui ci avec
les super héros nous avons les identités
secrètes oui j'ai une identité secrète
vous en avais jamais parlé parce que
c'était secret mais vous aussi vous avez
une identité secrète vraiment port de
web nous sommes à la fois des individus
authentique comme quand on est avec
notre famille nos avis et nos proches et
à la fois des personnages factice qu'on
est face à un professeur ou un supérieur
par exemple quand on est en rendez vous
à la banque on n'y va pas naturel
d'ailleurs le banquier lui même ce
jour-là n'est pas naturel il enfile son
rôle de banquier à ce moment là même moi
quand je fais une vidéo en fait je ne
suis pas complètement le fait bien de la
vraie vie pouvait ce que je veux dire et
même plus généralement on a tous une
identité secrète que d'autres personnes
ne voient jamais qui se révèle que dans
l'intimité du coup les petites voix
bizarre les petites private joke les
petits vous savez l'idée émise par le
sociologue erving goffman est d'ailleurs
très juste quand il dit que la vie
sociale ne serait qu'une succession de
scènes de théâtre dans lequel nous
jouons un rôle en fonction des attentes
car notre groupe social envers nous on
prend le rôle qui est attendu de nous à
ce moment là nous avons vu pourquoi les
super héros ni plestan mais au delà des
comics des films et des séries est ce
qu'il existe vraiment
super héros exister les super-héros
plaisent tellement et certains s'y sont
tellement identifié qu'ils en sont
devenus pour de vrai mais enfin prêt
mais ici il s'appelle fénix jones purple
rain ou encore mister extrême leur point
commun ils portent tous un costume qui
cachent leur identité civile et qui
montrent qu'ils sont de véritables
justicier ils patrouillent dans leur
ville pour faire régner l'ordre ou aider
les sdf d'autres personnes sont allés
jusqu'à créer certains gadgets de super
héros comme le youtuber bolt rl qui
s'est offert le grappin de batman
incroyable au delà de ceux qui veulent
rétablir la justice dans leur ville je
vous parlais dans le matière grise
numéro 7 que je vous mets dans la
description des pouvoirs que peuvent
développer les êtres humains à un
instant t parce que oui votre cerveau
peut vous transformer en super héros si
la situation le demande vous avez
peut-être déjà entendu parler de cette
jeune femme qui avait soulevé une
voiture pour sauver son père ou de ce
petit garçon de deux ans qui a soulevé
une commode qui était tombé sur son
petit frère ou encore c'est ado de 13
ans qui avait sauvé deux personnes d'un
coup de la noyade dans une avec un saut
de pierres autour du cou comment ça
marche et bien en situation de stress
notre cerveau et à plein régime et
d'autres corps sécrète de l'adrénaline
notre coeur bat plus vite et nos poumons
s'ouvre pour prendre un maximum
d'oxygène le corps peut faire à l'heure
face à une situation en étant plus
puissant plus rapide et aussi en
respectant pas trop les normes de
douleur ou d'habillement du corps et
parfois même le seul fait de se mettre
totalement en condition de danger pour
soi ou pour autrui permet de trouver des
capacités physiques un peu hors norme et
y en a un d'ailleurs qui aimeraient que
l'homme devienne un super héros au
quotidien c est le musk c'est d'ailleurs
en cours puisque ne ralink la start up
du milliardaire est en train de
développer un implant connecté au
cerveau qui pourrait notamment permettre
à des personnes paralysées de retrouver
la mobilité de leurs membres ça c'est
quand même très cool en mars 2021 elon
musk a présenté le singe tagueurs hadj
heures au grand public tadjeur un de ces
implants coller au cerveau il est
capable de jouer au jeu de pong par la
pensée uniquement grâce à son interface
neuronale elon musk a expliqué qu'une
personne dotée d'un tel un plan pour est
oui tu es plus vite qu'une autre qui
utilise ses pouces et ses doigts sur son
téléphone pour quoi faire c'est un plan
pourrait certes à terme aider des
personnes handicapées mais il pourrait
également servir à développer les
capacités de l'être humain en général
lesquels l'avenir nous le dira vous êtes
donc tous des super héros potentiels
capables de vous surpasser dans
certaines situations dans tous les cas
les super héros de fiction aux actions
altruistes semble avoir une bonne
influence sur notre comportement donc
c'est cool d'ailleurs vous c'est qui
votre super héros préférés est ce que
c'est vraiment un super héros ou est ce
que c'est un anti super héros je crois
que j'aime bien ce qu'ils ont quand même
des capacités spéciales de base pas ceux
qui ont juste de l'argent pour s'acheter
des trucs batman si tu m'entends désolé
du coup vous vous êtes plutôt par le
fait de développer les capacités des
êtres humains comme le souhaite le faire
lots de masques ou pas dites moi tout ça
dans les commentaires venez on débat moi
je m'appelle toujours fabien olicard
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à cette
chaîne est activé la cloche pour ne pas
rater la prochaine vidéo ce serait fort
dommage n'oubliez pas également qu'il ya
un bien dans la description vers
curieuse le prochain numéro là qui sort
le mois prochain ça parle des super
héros avec tout ce que je vous
expliquais bref pensez à vous abonner
vous pouvez passer voir sur le site pour
lire des articles gratuitement et voir
si ça vous plaît parce que vraiment 29
euros 90 par an pour un magazine de 60
pages mensuelles
on pouvait pas faire mieux je vends bien
ma sauce là mais je le pense vraiment
ici je vous mets deux autres vidéos la
joue mais le matière grise 7 dont je
vous parlais dans la vidéo est ici juste
à côté je vous mets un épisode sur
léonard de vinci était tellement un
génie que je me demande si ce n'était
pas un super héros quand même allez
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
ciao